kingdom hearts 4 has been announced and
it might include a star wars level
square enix has announced that
development is underway on kingdom
hearts 4 the next entry in the
long-running disney rpg series the news
came as part of a 20th anniversary
celebration event and included the
release of the very first trailer
kingdom hearts 4 kicks off a new
storyline for the franchise the lost
master arc sora returns but he's
sporting a new look the trailer
showcases some brief glimpses of
gameplay as sora squares off against a
giant shadow monster in the middle of a
city street this new location is
quadratum with square enix describes as
a large expansive city set in a gorgeous
realistic world unlike anything ever
seen before in kingdom hearts no further
details were shared on this location or
the overall gameplay or story donald
duck and goofy both return in kingdom
hearts 4 and a new mysterious character
will also be introduced there's no word
on what platforms kingdom hearts 4 will
be available for although kingdom hearts
3 was eventually released for pc xbox
one ps4 and nintendo switch with the
latter being a cloud streaming version
likewise there's no release date either
but fans seem to think square enix's
reveal of the new kingdom hearts may
have teased more than just a regular
crossover with disney's iconic
characters as many of those fans spotted
a brief glimpse of what appears to be
the foot of an all-terrain scout
transport in a location that could be
the forest moon of endor such a
crossover wouldn't be too surprising for
kingdom hearts 4. disney has acquired
more intellectual properties in the
years since kingdom hearts first debuted
such as marvel entertainment in 2009 and
the star wars franchise in 2012. with
avengers spider-man and star wars
characters part of the disney empire the
potential for bigger crossovers in
kingdom hearts 4 is possible over on
twitter fans said things like if we're
really getting a star wars world in
kingdom hearts 4 i can't wait to see
what the heartless designs for that
world will look like been thinking about
kingdom hearts 4 since yesterday and the
idea of star wars heck even marvel
worlds having inclusion in the franchise
considering the tonal shift has me uber
excited for what's to come kingdom
hearts looks cool star wars is a fun
idea but i hope they add shows because
pepper and fighting sephiroth is awesome
in more kingdom hearts news square enix
also announced a new mobile game called
kingdom hearts the missing link which
will have its first closed beta later
this year the gameplay features 3d
rendered environments plenty of
heartless to battle and what appears to
be customizable keyblade masters a
number of disney locations can also be
spotted in the trailer such as the
forest from tangle that was featured in
kingdom hearts 3. square enix added that
the closed beta will roll out later this
year in select regions although those
exact locations have not been revealed
an exact release date for the ios and
android device launch hasn't been nailed
down yet either this isn't the only
kingdom hearts mobile game available as
kingdom hearts dark road has been around
for a few years now square enix revealed
that the grand finale of the kingdom
hearts union x storyline will be
released for free in august let us know
in the comments how excited you are for
kingdom hearts 4 and what worlds you're
hoping to see